we all have a nostalgic soft spot for
the good old days in Nintendo the Super
Nintendo was my first console and if you
want to use a controller from that era
with a few modern touches 8-bit do has
you covered the SM 30 Pro and the SF 30
Pro are pulled fully featured Wireless
game pads for your switch PC and Android
phones one of these controllers is gonna
run you 50 bucks and you won't be
missing out on any functionality you get
two triggers two bumpers to smooth and
grippy analog sticks that also click
downward all packed into the throwback
mold of the SNES controller sure it
might be weird to see an SNES controller
with analog sticks but these function
really well as you can see the SF 30 Pro
rocks the Super Famicom color scheme
while the SN 30 pro rocks the Super
Nintendo color scheme these also have
motion controls which is a must-have
considering how important it is for
games like Super Mario Odyssey and
splatoon too these connect via bluetooth
and each platform has a different
pairing process that doesn't take too
long these controllers charge through a
USB C 2 USB 2.0 cable and these have
long battery lives on a full charge it
can last up to 16 hours through my
several hours of testing them I never
had to plug them back in off of a full
charge the buttons and analog sticks
feel great to use the triggers in
particular have a short throw but they
are a little on the small side so if you
have big hands it'll be hard to actuate
the classic design of the controller can
also make it a little hard to grip as
long as you clamp the controller tight
enough on both sides this shouldn't be
too much of a problem
I spent time and zelda breath of the
while to get a feel for how the SF 30
pro and the SN 30 pro hold up in a
full-fledged game I didn't have any
issues with how they function and it was
novel playing a 20-17 game with a
throwback gamepad admittedly a pro
controller is more comfortable
especially with the set of triggers and
analog sticks it has I also played a ton
of rocket League for a more intense
twitch based scenario again I had no
issues playing the game and nailing down
shots on goal however if you're super
high level player the precision of a pro
controller is gonna help these
controllers are ergonomically sound
considering they're bottled up to the
Super Nintendo and Super Famicom
controllers but I had one annoyance with
them when the controller vibrates and
makes a high-pitched squealing sound
now if you got headphones on are you
playing a game in a loud room it's not
gonna be a problem but the noise really
picks up in a quiet setting if you want
a fully-featured compact controller for
the Nintendo switch or the PC and you
dig the old-school designs from the SNES
days these are exactly what you're
looking for these aren't going to hold
up to the design of the Nintendo pro
controller and the squeaky vibrations
are kind of annoying but this modern
take on a classic controller from 8-bit
do is on point